Can you believe she said we were
destructive?
No!
(Glass shatters)
We're exactly the opposite!
We are CONstructive.
We're constructive!
♪♪
Charlie:
Okay.
Family movie night guys!
Sylvia:
Oh whoa.
What?
Will's getting a divorce.
So call him.
We literally haven't spoken to
each other in years.
Call him. That's what friends
do.
♪♪
Will:
Hey!
Sylvia:
How are you?
Great, how are you?
Sylvia:
How's the beer business?
Will:
I'm actually the brew master at
my own bar now.
Congratulations!
You still got that, uh, family
of yours?
You wanna see a photo?
Wow there they are. Cool.
♪♪
(Phone chimes)
What are you up to?
Oh! Why is this my life?!
So... lunch?
[Sylvia}
No.
Brunch?
No. I don't have time for this.
You can't be friends with a
girl.
There's lots of famous men and
women friends.
Laura Dern and Sam Neil in
Jurassic Park.
Your friendship with Will is not
built for this phase of life.
(Glass bottles shatter)
Oh geez!
This is how a woman experiences
a midlife crisis.
Audrey:
You're like a couple of teenaged
girls.
Your whole thing is so weird and
destructive.
(Garage collapses)
Can you believe she said we were
destructive?
No! We are exactly the opposite.
-We are CONstructive.
-We're constructive.
♪♪
I don't like feeling like the
second most important man in
your life.
-Dorito-saurus.
It's embarrassing being a mess
in front of you.
Sylvia:
And Will's a much bigger mess
than I am.
♪♪
All I want is for you to end up
happy you idiot!
Well I am happy. I've never been
happier in my life!
(Glass shatters)
Send me the invoice.
♪♪
Will:
Break out of your box. Do a
little nose candy with us.
Did they have CK back in the
day?
Andy:
It's like a mild horse
tranquilizer.
It's a horse tranquilizer?!
-Will Andy & Reggie:
Shhh!
-Sylvia: What?!
You can't blow it out! It's
already in the brain!
♪♪
In my defense, I thought it was
cocaine.
And just so I'm clear- that's
your defense?
The defense rests.